hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 mexican thriller movie called new
order the movie illustrates the gap
between the rich and the poor's in
mexico and shows us the consequences
that might occur from that social gap
the movie begins with an abstract
painting by the mexican artist
after that we jump to a scene of an old
man named rolando who is accompanying
his wife alisa at a hospital
suddenly the situation within the room
becomes chaotic
all the patients are forcibly taken out
and are replaced with seriously injured
demonstrators despite the patient having
severe illness
the doctor suggests he finds another
private hospital for his wife but it
will cost about
000 pesos which is a huge amount of
money despite all the chaos and riots
happening in the city on the other side
a post-wedding party of marion and her
husband is being held at a luxury
mansion
all the elites who attend the party are
having fun without caring about stuff
happening in the city the girl in red is
the daughter of ivan an influential
person in the government
marianne gives the presents given by the
guest to her mom and she takes it to the
safe
the rich actually realize the rebellion
is happening as the water turns into
green but they just don't care
feeling insecure the mother orders the
house's head waitress marta seek out the
green paint a few moments later a
powerful senior government official
victor arrives at the party and he
discusses the land permit with the boys
claiming that it has been approved
realizing that the danger is getting
closer victor and his family immediately
leave the wedding party
while the guests are enjoying the party
suddenly rolando shows up at his former
employer's house begging the mother for
money for his wife's emergency surgery
he humbly requests 200 000 pesos to
cover the medical expenses
she returns to the party and asks ivan
and daniel to lend her some money she
manages to gather 35 000 pesos and hands
them over to rolando however the money
is not enough and he wants to ask for
more he greets marianne and tells the
situation to her who is very keen to
help him
daniel approaches the old man and gives
him some money asking him to leave
afterwards
marianne tries to open the safe and lend
the jewelry and money inside it to
rolando but the password was changed she
approaches the family members but no one
is willing to help which makes the bride
furious
left with no option she brings her own
credit card and heads over to the
mansion's entrance but rolando has left
along with driver christian they
secretly leave and go to the hospital as
they drive marianne finds out that the
roads around her mansion have been
blocked off by the police to anticipate
the incoming attacks and they are forced
to turn back
a man on the radio reveals that the
protesters have taken over the streets
but there is still no response from the
authorities
back to the mansion the protesters
painted in red and green have breached
into the house
their leader shoots ivan and the
situation in the house becomes chaotic
instead of helping his employer the head
of security felipe shoots the guests and
helps the attackers to raid the house
while felipe takes the mother as hostage
and forces her to open the safe the
workers plunder all the stuff and
treasures within the house
as soon as it opens he kills her luckily
marta is still faithful to her employer
and secretly calls her son telling him
not to come back to the house but
suddenly she is spotted and is knocked
down
the rich are punished because of their
greed and arrogance destroying the
famous painting and even daniel's
pregnant wife is killed in the process
marianne and christian return to the
house but immediately go away as the car
is surrounded by the protesters
using alternate routes they eventually
arrive at the city where the protesters
are wreaking havoc they stop by
christian's house and are welcomed by
rolando
turns out that he is the nephew of the
old man
christian attempts to contact the
authorities but the phone lines are dead
marianne promises elisa that she will
bring her to the hospital
later that night marta awakens and
discovers that the mansion has turned
into nothing she walks home while the
chaos is still ongoing the next day ivan
is brought to the hospital and
everything is now under control in the
mansion
marianne wants to return home while
christian goes outside the house to
check the situation he is confronted by
several military soldiers who offer
their services to escort the girl home
these soldiers are rude and unexpectedly
force marianne to hand over her phone
earrings ring and watch to them the city
has turned into a mess and dead bodies
can be found all over the place in the
city
instead of bringing her home marianne is
brought to a military base
there she and all prisoners are treated
rudely by the soldiers they are
deliberately kidnapped and most of them
are the relatives of rich people and
influential politicians in the city each
of them is ordered to write down their
personal information and contacts that
later on will be used for blackmailing
later that night all women are awakened
and are forced to satisfy the soldier's
desire
on the other side daniel is devastated
when he is asked to complete the
administration for his wife and mother's
funeral
daniel and the husband approach victor
who agrees to help to find marianne and
introduces general orybay to them
the following day a funeral for the lost
family members is being held
after the funeral ivan is discharged
from the hospital and he continues his
medical treatment at his house
victor visits him giving him hope that
he will find his daughter their reign
and power starts falling apart as their
servant is not as obedient as before to
their employer
back at the military base the soldiers
purposely record videos of the prisoners
begging to be released and then send it
to their relatives or families demanding
a large ransom from them at this point
the military already has full control
over the citizens and all of them are
forced to comply worried by his wife's
condition rolando goes out and begs the
soldiers to allow him to cross the
border to find a doctor
they ignore his request and shoot him to
death on the spot it is then shown that
elisa was dead due to the illness and
without any treatment both of them
eventually rest in peace the husband
receives the recording from the
prisoners who demand a million for the
release fee the brothers immediately
approach victor and the commander
showing them the footage from the
soldiers
marianne's kidnappers learn that they
will only receive around 200 000 pesos
from the leader but they are unsatisfied
with the share later that night they
secretly come to christian and urge him
to give him 800 000 pesos if he wants to
see her alive
the next day using the provided
transportation mode and their work
permit christian and marta visit their
employer to deliver the unsettling news
desperate and left with no option ivan
agrees with the 800 000 pesos release
fee and daniel gives the money to the
driver they then return to their house
and hand over the cash to the kidnappers
however the greedy soldiers state that
the 800 000 pesos is just a down payment
and they will come again to collect the
other 1 million pesos
back to the military base prisoner
number 3 is released because his family
pays the ransom however he is shot to
death as soon as he gets out of the cell
indicating that no one will be returned
to their families
the next day marta and christian explain
the situation to marianne's husband
unhappy and feeling suspicious he
immediately calls victor accusing the
servants of kidnapping marianne
as a result the two kidnappers and the
others are arrested by the police
after that marianne is taken away from
the military base by the commander
himself while the others are eliminated
one by one she thinks that she is safe
and has been rescued by the commander
however she is brought to christian's
house where the driver has been waiting
the police immediately shoot marianne in
the bathroom and give the gun to
christian framingham and killing him
afterwards the following day the husband
is informed by victor and the commander
that his wife was shot to death
at the end of the movie it is seen that
ivan is attending the execution ceremony
with victor and the commander sitting
next to him acting like they didn't do
anything dirty there marta who is the
victim of the upper high's cruelty has
her face covered and executed since then
the new order under the military command
has been formed and people with no
privileges are left with no option but
to comply
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching